please welcome let's get star struck
it's larae
hello hi
you really it's such a big deal that
you're here thank you so much thank you
for having me and also you guys all look
amazing i'm still freaking out a little
bit i am too fan big fan for sure i mean
my daughters are freaking out everyone
is freaking out it is such an amazing
thank you thing that you've built this
thank you so much career this following
this empire
and you have made this really awesome
food which i was saying to you before we
came on it's very serendipitous that you
make my favorite food on planet earth i
mean it's very weird that i do make your
favorite food on planet earth my number
one food um on planet earth that i could
eat every day for the rest of my life is
macaroni and cheese but you have larae's
loaded mac
and
why did you start this and what's it all
about i cannot wait to try so i guess
it's it's honestly stemmed for my
grandma mac and cheese is her favorite
thing she cooks it for every single
family cookout
so when i told her about it she was like
what are you talking about larry's on
the mac it was a huge surprise and the
moment i showed her she actually fell in
love the second she took a bite and i
think
um
making her proud and just honestly
keeping the family thing going and
making you know this
due to her it's like so special to me
like that's actually a good question
like you have hundreds of millions of
people watching you yeah is it getting
grandma's approval i think so my
grandma's validation i'm such a
grandma's and mama's boy so like just
getting their validations i'm fine
that's all i need i do not need anything
else i love that well i am so excited i
have been waiting a while to try this
can't wait
i'm so excited for you to try this where
do i go okay so actually we have seven
mac and cheeses but i only brought my
favorite four that honestly reminds me
of you so we have hottie
yeah
yeah
[Music]
thank you larae um this one
oh she's such a i like oh my god so much
thank you of course miss gear
so hottie basically consists of buffalo
chicken
ranch shredded carrots yeah and a whole
lot of mac and cheese girl oh my god a
whole lot of mac and cheese
oh my god
we had someone on the show here
a couple weeks ago and i fell so in love
with him that i asked him to come back
actually
and he is going to taste alongside of me
he actually speaks much better about
flavors than i do very eloquent please
welcome my dear friend kareem come on
kareem
i did this
[Music]
you have little ramekins to taste
alongside why don't you start with the
buffalo chicken and tell me what you
taste i'm so hungry right now like i've
been waiting for this since yesterday
oh he's fishing okay buffalo cheese
let's do it i'm gonna make it can i get
that assist
oh my god
are you
by the way i think this is amazing oh
wow
get into the crunch really get into it
i'm in the crunch
[Music]
this is absolutely busting oh yeah do
you know what busting means
busted is um well i know what it used to
mean
bus didn't used to mean like not looking
good but i said that there's busting no
busting
well because like netflix and chill i
kept saying like i want to netflix and
chill because back in my day chilling
meant relaxing and now it means
something else
so i was
coming off you know like
really provocative when all i thought i
was doing was wanting to wear sweatpants
and watch movies
so what is bustin bust in this tick-tock
slang for like the best thing ever um
[Applause]
[Music]
so this is feeling risky this one
basically has a barbecue
burritos oh pool of pork all right
kareem you want to do this together oh i
already started okay good perfect
how you feel about that korean
does that make you tingle
i'm gonna have to have a word with my
mother and my grandmother
i know that's right because my mom's mac
and cheese does not taste like this i'm
a little bit upset about it it's okay
the same i'm gonna have to send her a
box it's really really good very
different the mac and cheese is giving
me the consistent element but the flavor
profiles are drastically different
very impressive you said it's tick tock
slang you even know you did it i did
what did i use it's giving me oh and
that might be something let me do
something else so let's say this you can
say it's giving cheese i love the word
chugi that's my new favorite saying
do you not know chugi what's a chugi oh
my god larae am i going to teach you a
gen z or term teach me a chewy word
chugi is when something is like just not
cool out of date and like lame oh i'm
gonna get into chooky all right what is
this one i see these beautiful this one
it is that girl
she's that girl am i right guys
i'm in personal hype and i have to
so this one's basically my also favorite
it's um basically a pizza vibe we got
your tomatoes pepperonis and some
mayonnaise to top it off
it's literally just a pizza kareem you
with me ah
cheers
oh wow i love this one
oh whoa
get into the tomato i have a whole
tomato in my mouth oh i love her
that's really impressive do you actually
like she's really liking me no i love
this
what it felt like to me was the scene
one with in and when harry met sally oh
that's what it feels like feels really
good
i like she's like yes yes yes
[Applause]
those whole tomatoes are um really a
thing of beauty thank you which one is
this flavor profile this is lbt what is
lbt well everyone knows what blt means
right yes wilson simon
right i switch the words around a little
bit i love it
i love it
okay i'm going in kareem this is bacon
tomato
some good old cheese
mmm that's my grandma's favorite just so
good kareem thoughts
don't mid-bite every time
[Laughter]
i think that there are a lot of problems
in this world
oh
and the little rey's
loaded macintosh is not not one of those
oh you all paid him to say that
[Applause]
thank you
you're amazing and the raised loaded mac
is available virtually via most every
major food app and we will be right back
[Music]
you